cities across America force law abiding
citizens into curfew as rioters and
looters burn and smash protesters
watched their cause undermined by
violent hangers-on and Democrats in the
media keep feeding the flames I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
well visit expressvpn comm slash pens
you stay anonymous so I leave for three
days you burn down the country that's
how this works
I mean I had a Jewish holiday on Friday
and then a Jewish holiday on Saturday
and I come back on Saturday night and
half the country is in flames and let me
just make this clear right at the very
top if you are a rioter if you are
looter you're human scum you're doing
nothing positive for society what you
are acting on is not quote unquote
justified anger you're a piece of crap
you're a piece of crap
and you should be arrested you should be
prosecuted business owners should defend
their businesses
this is sheer unbelievable garbage and
the failure of government to perform its
single function which is to protect the
law-abiding that failure of government
is catastrophic I'm talking from local
governments to state governments to the
federal government the lack of ability
of the government to do the one thing it
is supposed to do right this government
that's supposed to provide you
everything that you could possibly need
provide you privileges from the top
instead it can't even protect you in
your own cities this government and so
the government is designed to protect
life and liberty in the case of George
Floyd they didn't either and then they
allowed rioters to run roughshod
throughout the country we had most every
major American city last night under
curfew LA County which is 10 million
people Winston's curfew yesterday at 6
o'clock p.m. Santa Monica went into
curfew at 4 o clock p.m. this is not a
free country so I have some good news
here's the good news
apparently Cova 19 is over apparently
it's over because what I saw over the
weekend and Saturday night and Sunday
what I saw was tens of thousands of
people in the streets and nobody giving
a good gosh-darn because bottom line is
they were doing something that the media
agreed with and so there are three
things that we need to talk about today
one is the legitimate cause of fighting
police brutality the second is the
illegitimate argument that America is
endemically racist systematically racist
racist at every level and that America
must apologize for its very being that
America must be May
remade from bottom to top and top to
bottom and then there is the third
argument that some are making which is
the people who riot and loot are somehow
an outgrowth of justified anger that
somehow going and smashing a store
window makes you some sort of hero in
this society it's bull it's bull if you
are a rider if you're a looter you ought
to be captured you ought to be arrested
you ought to be prosecuted this is this
is not the behavior of a civilized
country it is not and don't tell me that
the behavior of the police officer in
George Floyd situation was done simplest
I agree we all agree we're all on the
same page
that guy's in jail he's going to remain
in jail he should be in jail the only
question is on what charge what does the
evidence support no one disagrees on
this if you say people weren't acting in
civilized fashion with a mode are baring
I agree those guys are in jail they
belong in jail everyone agrees on this
by using this as an excuse to destroy
the Lincoln Memorial to go in tad the
World War Two memorial to beat business
owners outside their business and to do
it on the basis of race have you seen
some of the signs that men put up in
these cities people attempting to put a
black lives matter signs in their
windows to dissuade rioters from
breaking their windows I don't think
most of this is black lives matter by
the way I think black lives matter is a
cause with which some of its points I
disagree I think that they make an
overwrought case as to the nature of
America itself which is the second
argument we're gonna talk about today
but the people who are mostly smashing
windows are folks from an tyfa and
people who are vile hangers-on who are
attempting to grab a TV you're not
honoring George Floyd's memory or doing
anything good for America or fighting
police brutality by stealing a TV or
just a piece of if you are stealing a TV
you are a bad on the back of the of the
killing of an innocent black man you're
a bad person red white or green this is
insane and for all the people who need
your saying well you can't pay attention
to this you're paying attention of this
you're not paying attention to all the
other bad stuff that's happening in the
country I can walk and chew gum at the
same time not only that we spent an
entire episode on off Matar berry we
spent entire episodes talking about
George Floyd everyone again agrees on
this stuff he attempt
to polarize America around the question
of whether rioting and looting is a
justified uprising I'm seeing language
of uprising that's an uprising that's
not an uprising what do you rising up
against target is target the great
oppressor and yes I'm angry because
you've shut millions of Americans in
their homes tens of millions of
Americans you have shut in their homes
law-abiding Americans and you're burning
down businesses and you're breaking
store windows and you're hurting people
who are disproportionately minority by
the way you're really hitting stop shops
in most of these cities that are owned
by black people owned by Hispanic people
owned by Asian people and somehow this
is this is being treated by celebrities
as justified he's hurting it's in the
news in just one second but I just
thought that I'd put that up front that
if you're defending this if you're
defending this behavior you're part of
the problem and I think there's some
Democrats today thank God for coming out
and not defending this I think that
there are a lot of black leaders who are
coming out today and not defending this
nor should they defend this because no
leader of any race should defend any of
this because this isn't a black-white
issue this is just is it not a race
issue routing is not a ratio a race
issue and police brutality should not be
a race issue it's just a human decency
issue these are all human decency issues
and it breaks my heart for my country
that the that the human decency that we
should all be united around seems to
have been thrown out the window
completely to the point where people are
defending rioters and looters because
America is bad or people are suggesting
that Americans don't care by and large
when a white police officer puts his
knee on the neck of a black man for
eight minutes who are the people who
don't care about this stuff who and
we're gonna get to the actual news in
just one second but if you're if you
woke up not angry this morning then it's
because you haven't been watching the
news and it is justified anger to ask
why in the hell living in the the freest
most prosperous country in the history
of mankind we had 50 million citizens
last night were confined to quarters not
on the basis of a virus for their own
protection but on the basis of people
running roughshod through the streets
and throwing Molotov cocktails of cop
cars nuttiness and by the way where's
President Trump
President Trump needs to get his ass in
gear okay not these tweets are not
sufficient these are not sufficient he
needs to be on TV tonight and President
Trump needs to be telling people that
whatever your cause we value the First
Amendment in this country we do not
value violence not only do we not value
violence we were going to make the full
weight and power of the federal
government available to any mayor or
governor who calls for its help all
resources will be used to stomp this
sort of violence out none of this is
good for the country none of this is
decent for the country none of this
affects change in fact it affects
precisely the reverse of a lot of the
kind of change that some of the
protesters are protesting for this is
madness it's just madness okay well
we'll get to we'll get you more of this
madness and what exactly has been
happening in just one second first let's
talk about something that can calm you
down just a little bit I'm talking of
course about the smell of a delicious
seared steak topics here but let's be
real about this Father's Day is coming
up you're still gonna need to buy dad a
gift a great gift
Omaha Steaks oh they sent me some kosher
steaks I mean these things are just
top-notch absolutely delicious when JJ
Simon and his son immigrated to the
United States from Latvia in 1898 they
settled in Omaha Nebraska they worked as
butchers for the local community for 20
years before their business became so
successful they started distributing to
grocers hotels and distributors it was
the start of what we now all know and
love as Omaha Steaks Omaha's
world-famous takes their naturally aged
at least 21 days for tenderness
hand-carved to perfection they also
offer tasty easy to make side dishes
artisan desserts also some of my
favorites and much much more
Omaha Steaks has been America's original
butcher since 1917 Lamanna steaks
guarantees delivers guaranteed quality
and safety with every order all backed
up by an unconditional 100% money back
guarantee every home Omaha Steaks order
is flash-frozen vacuum sealed safely
delivered in a cooler with dry ice which
means fresh meat I mean this is
delicious delicious stuff I can tell you
from personal experience can they sent
me some kosher product it is just
top-notch top-notch stuff you're not
gonna do better for dad this Father's
Day right now Omaha Steaks is offering
my listeners access to a variety of
amazing packages perfect to send for
Father's Day you go to Omaha Steaks calm
and you enter code Shapiro's into the
search bar to a lock savings from our
listeners of 50% and more and free
shipping on orders over ninety-nine
bucks
there are many packages available
they're all ready to be shipped straight
to his door in time for Father's Day
head on over to Omaha Steaks calm enter
the code Shapiro at is Omaha Steaks calm
enter code Shapiro to shop for father's
day today in that search bottle and lock
all sorts of fantastic savings this is
delicious
you're going over that your dad's gonna
love it more importantly okay so what
exactly is happening in the here and now
according to the Washington Post pockets
of the United States descended into
chaos sunday is another day of mass
demonstrations over the death of yet
another black man in police custody led
to another night of fire and fury even
the way this is phrased by The
Washington Post demonstrates their take
on what America is the death of yet
another black man in police custody yet
another okay yes there have been more
than one black people more than one
black person has died in police custody
but the implication of Washington Post
of course is that there is a widespread
systematic brutality put upon black
Americans across America by nearly every
Police Department and that is just not
true it is not statistically true that
does not mean there are not racists in
police departments it does not mean that
there is not police brutality which is
effectuated against populations in which
police in which police officers come
into contact with populations police
brutality can be effected against black
people against Latino people against
against white people I mean the cases of
police brutality are too numerous to
mention and usually it's a problem of
training and a problem of who are you
recruiting to the police forces but the
Washington Post is implication here is
that of course all police policing
across America is endemically racist
because America has not changed from
1960 and on where Jim Crow lives on
today we'll see this is the argument
being made by actual columnist over at
the New York Times protests that began
peacefully exploded into mayhem as
windows were smashed stores were looted
buildings were vandalized in police
vehicles were torched the unrest spread
from Chicago Atlanta and Boston to
Sacramento Seattle and Sioux Falls South
Dakota as protesters and police clashed
outside the White House for a third
consecutive night President Trump
tweeted a call for law and order and the
tweets ain't gonna be sufficient mr.
president get on TV tell America what
you're going to do to stop this violence
tell America what you are going to do to
re-establish some semblance of
civilization because this is madness in
some cities law enforcement officers
were seen marching and kneeling with
protesters elsewhere police in riot gear
continued to increase their use of force
which added to the disorder early Monday
Kentucky governor Andy Beshear ordered a
state investigation after a man was
fatally shot during an overnight
confrontation with Louisville police in
the National Guard more than half of the
nation's governors have called on the
National Guard to help quell the unrest
meanwhile at least 45 million Americans
were under curfew Sunday night many
cities have extended their overnight
restrictions by the way I will point out
here that the lockdown is from Kovan 19
have you absolutely not helped
situation here when you put 40 million
Americans out of work and most of them
are disproportionately young and they
have nothing to do on a Sunday afternoon
or a Saturday night or Friday you're
gonna get much larger protests and
that's not to call into question their
their passion for these issues that is
to suggest that when people have jobs
they sometimes have to go to those jobs
as opposed to being out on the streets
protesting and violating all of the Cova
19 restrictions in the first place
weird how everybody who's deeply worried
about anti lockdown protesters not
wearing masks and socially distancing
doesn't give two craps about people who
are in the streets 20,000 strong as long
as they're protesting for a Cause the
members of the media agree with a number
of major retailers including Walmart
Target and Apple have temporarily closed
their stores in some areas rocked by a
people by the way worth noting here if
you are worried about the availability
of grocery stores and pharmacies and all
the things that people need in
predominantly black areas you know it'd
be a great solution to that fighting
back by local governments against the
rioting and against the looting you want
a reason why grocery stores and CVS's
are not opening up in low-income areas
in some cases they're not doing it
because they're afraid that it comes
with increased cost this would be a good
example of why a Walmart is not going to
open an open in an area where it was
looted two years ago more than 4,000
people are arrested in US cities over
the weekend according to the Associated
Press New York Mayor Bill de Blasio's
daughter Chiara was among the hundreds
of people arrested in the city after
failing to disperse law enforcement
sources told The Washington Post again
people have been told for years that the
that America is deeply evil on every
level that every anecdotal incident of
bad behavior is both racist and
indicative of America's broader racism
and thus America pro2 anything any
measure you take against the American
superstructure is therefore okay some
conservative commentators are urging the
President to address the nation yes
that would be me he's the President of
the United States and hiding behind
twitter ain't gonna do it it isn't he
has a job this is where being president
would actually be a useful thing okay so
what did all of this look like looked
horrible so there were riots at the
White House last night apparently 50
Secret Service agents were harmed in
these riots at the White House last
night here's a little bit of what that
looked like you can actually see it I
mean the big protest at the White House
people were starting to push
the he's so the Secret Service officers
people were grabbing the officers
shields over the weekend that got so bad
the president was put in the bunker
people on twitter law i what a weakling
the president goes to the curb right
he's the president it's literally
driving Secret Service to keep him safe
I have a question
what does President Trump have to do
with a Minneapolis police officer
putting his knee on the neck of a black
suspect in a democratic city that has
been ruled by Democrats for 50 years
like the but again this is going to be
turned into a question of America writ
large as I've said there are a bunch of
issues here okay the issue number one we
should all agree on riders and looters
as we will see evil evil evil evil a
second protesters many of them are angry
for good reason about police brutality
some are angry for batteries and
suggesting that all of America is
indicated in police brutality or that
all police forces across America are
racist but they're exercising the First
Amendment rights not even close to in
the same category with the rioters and
the looters and then there's the and
then there is the other question here
which is the George Floyd case but the
George Floyd case had been left far
behind this is I mean the fact is that
most of the protesters are moving far
beyond the facts of the George Floyd
case and certainly all the riders and
looters don't give two craps about
George Floyd if you are breaking a store
window on behalf of George boy let me
just tell you George Floyd's family
doesn't appreciate it you know who said
that George Floyd's family we'll get to
all this in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that with the
economy reopening hey guys Koba 19 is
over we got 20,000 people on the streets
with the economy reopening people are
going to need to be hiring in fact we
have a great story out of Italy today
that perhaps coronavirus we'll get to
this a little bit later in the program
perhaps coronavirus is actually losing a
lot of attentive lost its strength which
would be amazing in great news for
America and for the world
bottom line is the economy's gonna
reopen when it does real and you're
gonna need a job and if you're an
employer you're gonna need the best
employees this is why you need zip
recruiter zip recruiters focus has not
changed they're still doing what they
have always done helping people find
work helping businesses find the right
people for their open roles if you're
looking for a job zip recruiter is
working with you to find the right job
faster they are dedicated to helping you
get hired from caretaking to delivering
food and goods to building medical
facilities supplying protective
equipment and so much more in fact zip
recruiters app will send you up-to-date
job openings so you can be one of the
first to apply if you're actively hiring
zip recruiter will invite candidates to
apply
your most urgent roles making it faster
and easier to reach the people you need
by connecting people who need jobs and
companies that need people zipper career
is working with all of us so we can keep
moving forward this is deeply important
in a time as volatile and and disturbing
as this we need to get people back to
work we need them at work now and we
need employers able to find best
employees and we need you to be able to
find the job that you want this is why
you need zip recruiter go check them out
at zip recruiter comm slash work
together again that zip recruiter comm
slash work together
zip recruiter comm slash work together
okay so over the weekend the Minneapolis
government you want to talk about
failures of government the Minneapolis
mayor withdrew the police from a
precinct withdrew them and protesters
rioters okay I'm gonna make a real hard
distinction here rioters promptly burned
the place to the ground they promptly
set it on fire and burned it here's a
little bit of the news coverage this is
a look from above and on the ground of
the police station
burning overnight out of control this
was the very police precinct where the
four officers involved in the death of
46 year old George Floyd worked look at
overnight there protesters set off
fireworks outside rioters even got
inside the police station all staff had
been evacuated earlier as the protests
began hey meanwhile police cars were
being burned across the country they're
burned in Los Angeles they're burned in
Cleveland they're burned in Colombia
people just setting police cars on fire
as though this is somehow normal this is
not normal these are images from a third
world country these are not images
typically from the United States at
least not since 1968
the last time I saw anything like this I
was eight years old and it was Los
Angeles Riots this is full-scale
insanity here's some of that footage now
I think one of the cars is burning in
the background as they're really
becoming aggressive and moving people
back
we see a lot here yeah there we can see
in an aerial shot is that the police
have been told that they are supposed to
allow people to do this that is how this
happens the police have been told by the
mayor and they are supposed to allow
people to do this in the middle of Los
Angeles miss is downtown LA and you're
seeing cars burning on the sidewalk
police cars being set on fire ok this is
this is a failure of local governance on
the on the highest level on the highest
level and no you're not add and here if
you sent a police car on fire what is it
you know what you're gonna need it turns
out most people they need the police you
know he's calling the police when a
crime gets committed everyone black
white and green you're all calling the
police a targets were being burned
across the country targets were being
attacked across the country people are
breaking into target and breaking open
the ATM well that ATM ain't gonna be
involved in systemic racism anymore good
job everybody has solved racism you
broke into an ATM you looted the bras
off the off the store shelves at Target
well done everyone Wow fighting the
power you fought the power I have a
feeling this has nothing to do with
George Floyd nothing and feelings has
nothing to do with police brutality you
can tell you see the anarchist symbol on
the window there right that would be the
anti feh that be on t for putting up
putting those up there people in the
media pretending nc4 doesn't exist
they absolutely exist just because
they're not top-down coordinate it does
not mean they don't exist but here
people gotta grab a pair of gym shoes
for George Floyd guys really really
important stuff we wanna talk about
undermining the cause of fighting police
brutality this would be the one this
would be the one target has to be taken
down meanwhile you had protesters
chanting eat the rich as they were
trying to loot Rodeo Drive yesterday but
wow you're making America a better place
one smashed window at a time clearly
you've you've made your voices heard
good good job guys your protesters
screaming eat the rich on Rodeo Drive by
the way disproportionately white crowd
here screaming white the eat the rich
what the what the hell what the hell
does Rodeo Drive have to do with George
Floyd is there a police station there
like what the hell do nice shops have to
do with with George Floyd the idea that
the police are our protector
the systematic hierarchy is the bottom
line here that's that that is what is
actually prevailing and that gets you
from the from the looting and the
rioting to the actual argument that's
being made which is that it's the same
system that kills George Floyd that is
responsible for Rodeo Drive right that's
the underlying message that is being put
for we're gonna get to that in just one
second all of this is just the property
damage by the way and by the way I don't
want to hear from people declaring
themselves amoral I saw Sally Cohen do
this while all these places have
insurance okay really
last I checked stealing people's stuff
is evil theft is evil breaking into
someone's store is evil and the fact
that there's an insurance company that
they pay money out of their own pocket
to insure against this sort of stuff
does not alleviate the evil and there
was looting over at the Grove last night
the Grove is a very nice sort of a
public-private project in the middle of
Los Angeles and the Fairfax District
people burn down the the police they've
like a tiny little police Hut there
basically they broke into the Apple
Store they broke into the Nordstrom over
there all this for George Floyd well
done everyone just really well done
again I keep saying it over and over but
if you're the protesters and you're not
pissed at the rioters today you're doing
this wrong because guess who guess who's
losing sympathy for the protests
everybody who's watching the rioting and
watching the two conflated the smart
protesters know this by the way here are
some looting at the Grove yesterday
[Music]
people just breaking right into that
Apple store grab yourself an iPad for
George Floyd
really important stuff stealing an
iPhone for George Floyd everybody's
having me selves a grand old time
stealing stuff from Nordstrom's and
people just that by the way law
enforcement you're sitting there and
allowing this to happen right you can
actually see security there and law
enforcement doing nothing because
they've been told that they're not
supposed to do anything by these
feckless mayor's if you're a citizen of
these of these cities and you pay taxes
in these cities what the hell are you
paying taxes for when people who are
overtly committing crimes are being
allowed to run around freely and break
windows and do this kind of stuff
historic buildings somebody attempted to
burn down st. John's Church at Lafayette
Square in Washington DC last night that
is a church where abraham lincoln prayed
these images are these are not images
from the united states they're not this
is insane john's church is on fire the
parish office we went downstairs and it
is on fire I'm going to walk this way
and this is awful
we saw graffiti once the door was broken
we saw something similar happened
earlier and as you can see there's
definitely a fire here this is the
parish office here come on back this was
not just by the way that was not just
property damage we're gonna get to the
actual violence attacks on human beings
again I'm all for let's fight instances
of police brutality change police
procedures hire better people I'm just
wondering how it's not a national story
when people are being beaten in the
streets on a nationwide scale for
standing outside their businesses I'm
just wondering I'm just wondering why it
is that if you mention on Twitter that
this stuff is happening so well you
don't care about George Floyd how about
I care about George Floyd being killed
and I also care about the fact that 45
million Americans were confined to
quarters last night because pieces of
we're running around beating people up
on the streets of the United States how
can I not care like what again basic
human decency suggests that you should
care about all of these things but
apparently basic human decency is too
much to ask these days because if you
point to one issue this means that
you're ignoring the other absolute
insanity now we're gonna go to more of
this in just one second so it may be the
last night you forgot to brush your
teeth why maybe you were super stressed
watching the news and about you I was
pretty super stressed watching the news
but you can't afford to leave your teeth
without being brushed and this is why
you need to effectively brush your teeth
and floss renewed good health starts
with good habits quit makes it
by delivering all the oral care
essentials you need to brush and floss
better the quip electric toothbrushes
time sonic vibrations with 30 second
pulses to guide a dentist recommended 2
minute routine
there's even in size down version
designed for kids paired with quips anti
cavity toothpaste and mint or watermelon
you get all the ingredients teeth
actually need and none they don't quit
also as an eco-friendly refillable floss
with a dispenser you keep for life an
expanding string that helps to clean in
between quick brush heads toothpaste
floss refills are automatically
delivered on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just $5
each a friendly reminder when it's time
for a refresh and to stay committed to
your oral health in shipping is free
turn over 3 million happy customers and
practice good oral care easily and
affordably with quip starting at just
$25 again oral hygiene doesn't take a
lot of time but you got to do it right
and this is why I quit makes it super
easy you're never gonna forget those new
brush heads again or have to run over to
the local pharmacy if you go to get
quipped comm slash Shapiro right now you
get your first refill free that is your
first refill free at get quip comm slash
Shapiro spelled GE tqu IP comm slash
Shapiro quit the good habits company get
quip comm slash repairs but wasn't just
property damage obviously although
Pacific like I'm very tired of his
nonsense that property damage doesn't
mean anything there's a black bartender
black fire firefighter who watched his
his bar that he was just about to get
open burned down over the weekend you
think maybe that matters I talked to a
small restaurant owner here in in the
area where I live it's a kosher
restaurant and this lady and her husband
put their life savings into this
restaurant and it was doing real well up
until Kovan 19 and then Kovan 19
happened and they've maintained their
business they've been able to stay alive
through takeout yesterday they're
located on Ventura Boulevard okay minute
Earl Boulevard is like the big Boulevard
in in the North Hollywood Encino Tarzana
area yesterday they were told by the
police that rioters might come down
their street so they should go buy some
plywood they should go buy some plywood
and plywood up their windows this is
just to pretend that this stuff doesn't
matter that property doesn't matter
private property doesn't matter if
private property doesn't matter to you
again that's because you don't care
about other people you don't care about
other people's rights because it turns
out we do have a right to life liberty
and property we have rights to these
things in the United States and
government was instituted to protect
these things and if government can't
protect them then people are gonna start
defending them themselves and it's gonna
get really really ugly out there so
government better get it
get its ass on top of these things it
better do it right now and then there
was the violence the pretending this
which was violence against property is
not true I saw the Minneapolis mayor
saying well brick-and-mortar is not the
same as human life you know what else is
kind of important human life
hey in Rochester New York thugs attacked
a business owner in Rochester New York
and there's no other word for it that is
not a racially tinged term if you hit an
elderly woman you're a thug I don't care
what race you are okay there's an
elderly woman standing outside her
business people were yelling at her and
then apparently her husband kind of
shows up and and one of these rioters
one of these looters who wants to loot
the business first he's you can see him
taking a piece of wood and breaking it
on the storefronts wait doing all this
for George Floyd presumably okay they
start to walk away that the husband
apparently comes out and you can see one
of these guys who this is a this lady
looks what maybe fifty five six years
old she'll sit make bad things 60 okay
and one of these guys is gonna turn
around and just clock her directly in
the face okay
disgusting disgusting these guys could
go to jail for life I mean that's just
it like they should go to jail this is
their their ah I mean this is so hard to
watch a man was beaten unconscious in
Dallas nearly killed in Dallas he's in
serious condition in the hospital
apparently who's defending his store
with a sword and he was overrun by a mob
and they were just curb stomping him he
was on the ground they were just kicking
him directly in the head a full crowd of
people is that doesn't have anything to
the cause or these just people who are
pieces of hey again you uh there's
another guy who's brutalized me but
these people are no less pieces of than
the officer who puts his knee on the
neck of a man and keeps it there for
eight minutes it's the same sort of
activity the this it here is a man
yesterday he was apparently trying to
defend an American flag he was chased
down he was punched in the back of the
head and now he's being kicked by the
way these are white guys who are doing
this literally kicked in the face so
they're presumably some antifoam members
kicking this guy in the face as he is
down the NYPD over the weekend was being
hit with Molotov cocktails and and then
when they when they you know are being
having bricks
and rocks and bottles filled with
apparently we came out today
that members van teeth have been
stashing bottles filled with gasoline
around the cities that is not something
that the protesters are doing notice I
make the hard distinction between the
protesters and the rioters and looters
they are not the same group of people
but the media are fully conflating the
two in order to justify the rioting and
the looting they're doing no service to
the to the actual cause that people are
marching for whatever disagreements I
may have with some of the implications
of that caused it to okay so the NYPD
was hit the Molotov cocktails last night
there was a black federal officer who
was killed in Oakland so how is that
useful there's a man who's wearing a red
hat and people up in this in South
Carolina apparently people thought that
he was some sort of trump supporter
which again it's not illegal to be a
Trump supporter in South Carolina or
anywhere else in the United States and a
crowd starts running after him and just
beats the living hell out of him you
know this is just it's beyond belief
it's beyond belief and of course this is
ending with situations of violence
people attempting to obstruct cars and
trying to rob cars and then people in
the car scared and doing something right
we saw this last night there's a
protester I assume a looter who is
attempting to assault a FedEx a guy in a
FedEx truck and the FedEx truck kept
driving he's like I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be pulled out of my car and beaten
nearly to death like Reginald any guy
got dragged underneath the car I mean
this is just this stuff cannot happen it
cannot happen in heinous this is so
awful and so tragic and so terrible for
the entire country
it truly is whatever your race this is
just nothing good is happening here
nothing good and the product of this is
not gonna be anything good either
anybody who suggests that it is gonna be
something good is getting it completely
wrong so naturally our politicians are
making excuses for this sort of activity
and fueling the flames and they're doing
so in a couple ways some of them are
actually like directly giving aid and
comfort to the rioters and looters and
then there are some people who are
Fanning the flames of the of the
protests but doing so in an
extraordinarily radical way again I
think there's for the 1,000th time
there's an absolute case to be made that
we should change procedures surrounding
police brutality there's an absolute
case to be made that contracts with
police unions ought not to have things
like sovereign immunity right there or
qualified immunity there they're there
plenty of
policy changes that we can argue about
and talk about but when you suggest that
the entire American infrastructure writ
large is racist and doesn't care when
people get killed in incidents of police
brutality you are a liar and you're
wrong okay and by the way when you fan
the flames by suggesting that what we
saw on TV was the execution of a black
man which is not what happened
okay that isn't what happened what you
saw in that in this particular case with
George Floyd was an act of assault that
ended with the death that is not the
same as a as a cold-blooded execution it
is an act of evil but it is not a
cold-blooded execution there there's a
difference okay what we're gonna get to
more of this in just one second because
our politicians are ill serving us in a
republic we're supposed to be having
conversations we're not supposed to be
winking and nodding at violence in the
streets because we think that it's
politically beneficial to do so we'll
get some more of this in just one second
this is so oh this is devastating we're
gonna get some more of this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
you probably don't want to go down to
the local autozone today now would be a
good time for you shop for your auto
parts online and good news you can do
that you know quickly you can easily go
check out Rock Auto calm rockauto.com is
much easier than walking into a store
and someone's demanding quick answers to
things like is your Odyssey and LX or
Annie X and they have to order the part
online anyway because there are so many
types of cars it's impossible to keep
them all stock you have access to
rockauto.com
at your desk and in your pocket Rock
Auto calm always offers the lowest price
as possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you spend up to
twice as much before the same part Rock
Auto comm is a family business serving
Auto Parts customers online for 20 years
go to Rock Auto comm to shop for auto
and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and who
yourselfers why spend up to twice as
much for the same parts of the
rockauto.com catalog is unique
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brands specifications and
prices that you prefer amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need Rock auto calm go to
rock Auto come right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about a spots so they know that we sent
you rock Auto calm alrighty well we're
gonna get back into the political
response to all of this which has been
it has ranged from
cowardly to disgusting I would say is
the
the political response to all this we've
seen a few people who have acted in
proper ways including the Democrat mayor
of Atlanta for example the Democrat
mayor of st. Paul has acted in an
appropriate way and then we have seen
our politicians and our media and our
celebrities acting like absolute
absolute garbage because everybody who's
decent is again on the same side of this
officers who put a knee on the neck of a
person who's saying he can't breathe and
keep it there for eight minutes
those people are pieces of people who
break windows and loot in response to
that our pieces of they're not
equivalently pieces of people who go and
beat the hell out of business owners our
pieces like I haven't cursed this much
on a podcast ever but my country also
has not been on fire in a time when we
should all be unified against acts of
evil it is an act of evil to put your
knee on the neck of a man white black or
green as he says I can't breathe for
eight minutes long it is an act of evil
to go burn down a store that someone put
their life savings into it is an act of
evil to beat the hell out of somebody
who's attempting to defend their
business it is an act of evil to throw
Molotov cocktails at cop cars these are
acts of evil if we can't all agree on
this we don't have a country if you
disagree on any of these things then we
can't have a country and yet what we are
seeing from our politicians is is
willingness to wink and nod at some of
this activity in the name of political
gain and that is horrific horrific and
particularly in the name of a political
narrative that is supposed to suggest
that all of America can't agree on these
things because here's the thing if you
agree with me on all of these things if
you agree with me that there are many
people out there who doing very bad bad
things if you agree with me then that
means that you're fundamentally decent
and I'm fundamentally decent and even if
we disagree on the implications of
policy we are fundamentally decent and
can have a fundamentally decent
conversation but if you can generate
some sort of political polarization off
the issue because you believe that
America is inherently evil and that
Americans are inherently evil the
natural result is going to be chaos in
the streets and that is what we are
watching right here and right now that
is what we are watching in some ways
this is the outgrowth of a mentality
that suggests that America as a giant
country is a is a lie America its
history its philosophy its culture our
garbage and then it deserves to be torn
out by the roots in some ways this is
the outgrowth of justification
of a campaign against America as it
stands and again I'm not talking about
protestors who protest police brutality
I'm talking about people who justify
rioting and looting I'm talking about
people who suggest that America is
inherently racist evil - today that
argument is inherently divisive and it's
going to lead to the breakdown of all
conversation and once the conversation
breaks down you'll end up with
situations where people defend violence
and that's exactly what you don't want
yeah we're gonna get to more of this in
just one second
first head on over to Daily wire calm
and subscribe as you know if you do
subscribe you get two of these tumblers
you'll have two steers tumblers they're
only available for our most exclusive
memberships here that's our all-access
all-access membership now includes two
of those the tumblers are literally
overflowing with tears at the thought of
the offer alone join us on all access
you get to join us for real time at Q&A
discussions available on both the
website and the daily wire app the the
all accesses are a lot of fun I wear
t-shirts I sing songs I do dances with
my fellow candlesticks you know you can
go check that out over at all access
live finally all access members also get
all of the benefits of our other
membership tiers including an ad-free
website experience access to all of our
live broadcast and show library access
to the shows mailbags the full three
hours of the ben shapiro show along with
dedicated editorials from moi if you're
not an all-access member you are kind of
missing out so head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe join all access
get 15% off with coupon code Shapiro
right now again that's Daly we're calm
at slash subscribe and we'll see you all
there this is the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so you've seen our media our celebrities
our politicians who are basically
winking and nodding at this at this sort
of evil our celebrities of course the
morons right if you're in the media or
if you're a politician you at least have
the these sort of wherewithal to
understand what you are doing and then
couch your terms if you're a celebrity
apparently or just a complete damned
so celebrities were donating bail for
protesters over the weekend they're
donating bail for and by the way not
protesters rioters over the weekend so
chrissy teigen
seth rogen steve carell were donating
money to bail out people arrested in the
nationwide protests by the way there
were hundreds of thousands of people
protesting over the weekend the people
who were arrested or by-and-large
committing crimes that's why they were
there
Siegen said she decided to make a
$100,000 donation after President Trump
declared Saturday night was mad tonight
at the White House she said in
celebration of whatever the eff Magga
night is I'm committed to donating
$100,000 to the bailout of protesters
across the country and then that was
matched by a bunch of other liberal
celebrities people like Jameela Jamil
she put in a thousand dollars of course
not a hundred thousand dollars and then
we saw Seth Rogen saying he had matched
a contribution and and James Blake and
Janelle Monae and Yara Shahidi
rapper no-name said she had donated a
thousand dollars to this Patton Oswalt
donated to it
Padma Lakshmi did this so what we're net
we're now bailing out people who
committed crimes really well done
everybody just well done stuff genius
genius stuff unbelievable okay meanwhile
yet cardi B who's tweeting out that
looting was okay because after all what
other outlets people have but to steal
shoes from a shoe Locker from a
footlocker she tweeted out they looting
in Minnesota and as much as I don't like
this type of violence it is what it is
too much peaceful March is too much
trending hashtags no solutions the
people are left with no choice well
teams like there are a lot of people who
are protesting who did not decide that
they were going to steal a pair of shoes
in order to protest at the death of
George Floyd seems like there were
hundreds of thousands of them in the
streets actually cardi B but car TV may
not know the difference between
criminality and non criminality
considering shoes to brag about the fact
that she lured men back to her hotel
room and then drugged them and sold
their crap so this is it this isn't an I
will say some of the celebrities are
just hilarious I mean like hilariously
stupid
Madonna put out a video of her son David
who her adopted son David who was black
dancing to Michael Jackson movie racism
solved Madonna problem solved
here is this video even even the left is
owning Madonna over this one even they
were like really lady what our celebrity
class we needn't we need a better class
of celebrity you really do gonna bail
out all these people Jane Fonda was on
CNN last night why the hell is Jane
Fonda on Sienna I have a question
seriously
what's his Jane what insight does Jane
Fonda have wearing oh I don't even know
she's either dressed up as Pablo Picasso
circa nineteen thirty-seven or she's
dressed up as a black panther I have no
idea which she was she was on last night
on CNN talking about this why why CNN
the trusted name in news bring on Jane
Fonda to talk about this stuff there
have been several articles talking Wonka
in Los Angeles this is taking people
back to 92 1992 or three when there were
that was rioting after film of police
beating Rodney King became public and
then the officers were never held
accountable and this is different and I
think it's important for us to recognize
that okay Jane Fonda on national TV okay
so she the the celebrities are of course
the morons
the celebrities are the people who say
the quiet part out loud it ended with
some fairly ironic stuff last night
because there was one there was one
sports writer I think as an NBA writer
who had written that you know looting
and rioting that's just the natural
consequence of a racist country and then
the looters and rioters came to his
neighborhood and start trying to break
in to the gated neighborhood where he
lives and he's like where are the police
like okay you can't have it both ways
members of the media though we're doing
the yeoman's work of trying to connect
the rioting and the looting to the
protests and this is this is complicity
in in violence trying to connect people
who are committing acts of heinous acts
of violence and evil with people who are
protesting is it's not helping the
protesters and it is making excuses for
people who are doing evil things
it's truly
Lester Holt in this and I honestly I
expected more of Lester Holt he did it
he did a whole bit last night in which
he suggested that people looting and
rioting were involved in a primal scream
of pain well that the expressions I saw
in some of the faces when people were
stealing TVs was not primal scream of
pain there were people who are who are
who are expressing pain in these
protests but the conflation between that
and burning cop cars is not clear to me
here is Lester Holt last night kick your
emotion chances are it was represented
in these jumbled images from America's
streets rage hate disappointment
emptiness hopelessness and so much fear
it's hard to comprehend that this was
about a singular event no matter how
horrific this explosion of raw passion
seeming to come from a place far deeper
a primal scream from a country that may
just be fed up
okay so again the attempt to conflate
all of these activities is really a
disservice to the protesters but it's a
disservice to America too because the
underlying the underlying argument that
Lester Holt is making here is the same
as the rest of the media today which is
that the riots and the looting and the
protests are all coming from the same
place and that is people are fed up with
America as it stands America is innately
evil in America if people get mad and
people tear things down well that's just
the way things go Spike Lee basically
made this explicit in an interview with
Don Lemon last night again I don't know
why Spike Lee is on TV talking about
stuff as a film director I'm not sure
what his level of expertise in any of
this is so here was Spike Lee with Don
Lemon last night basically excusing
writing alluding can I just read
something from someone who I highly
respect and watching our conversation
about condoning violence and they said
the answer - aren't you condoning
violence is no but I don't know what is
a proportional response to mass murder
Spike Lee
400 years we've been killed 400 years
okay that to equate what is happening in
the United States to black people right
now with 400 years of slavery and Jim
Crow is just disgusting it's disgusting
it's morally disgusting it's
historically ignorant it's ridiculous on
every level and that's the sort of crap
that's being promoted and by the way
when you say no but as everybody knows
what matters in that sentence is
everything after the botch and when you
are excusing rioting and looting well
you know it's bad but but what's the
proportional response to slavery slavery
formally ended in the United States in
1865 the Civil Rights Act was passed in
the United States in 1965 the the 6465
the basic notion that Americans in 2020
black Americans in 2020 are in any way
similarly situated to slaves or black
Americans living under Jim Crow is
absolute sheer crap but it is the it is
the media's attempt to basically suggest
that nothing has changed that this is
1968 Cornel West who's been saying this
all along he suggested that America is a
failed social experiment this does lay
bare a lot of the talk that is put
forward by the media people who are who
are for you want a Ford riots run a Ford
violence suggest that America's a failed
social experiment that America is
nothing more than an agglomeration of
random interests who are attempting to
gain leverage and power over each other
and so however people attempt to gain
leverage in power it's a dog-eat-dog
world man here's what Cornel West had to
say about America as a failed social
experiment if it is by the way if
America is a failed social experiment
there's nothing more to talk about
there's no more republic there's no more
voting it's useless
as we'll see you by the way there's some
Democrats who are not saying this kind
of stuff people like for example Barack
Obama who actually get put out a medium
post today and numbing the violence and
making a stark distinction between the
violence and the and what people are
protesting for I may disagree with him
on what people are protesting for but at
least he's condemning the violence
you're not getting any of that from some
members of the media and also the notion
that rioting and looting yeah we condemn
those but all white Americans are racist
in America's a racist system when you
tell people for four years for decades
that they are living under the boot of a
racist jackbooted system then violence
does become predictable it does become
predictable which is why maybe you
should stop telling the lie that America
is a racist jack
booted system in 2020 not in 1960 not in
1860 in 2020 there was Cornel West
suggesting America's a failed experiment
I think we are witnessing America as a
failed social experiment and what I mean
by that is that the history of black
people for over two hundred some years
and in America has been looking at
America's failure its capitalist economy
could not generate and deliver in such a
way that people could live lives of
decency the nation-state it's criminal
justice system is legal system could not
generate protection of rights and
liberties so here we are America's evil
Tara town Van Jones goes even further he
says all white people even most
well-intentioned white people have a
virus in their brain where they don't
recognize racism which suggests it's
gonna be kind of difficult to live in a
republic is it not it's kind of suggest
the end of the country does it not
here's Van Jones suggesting just that
it's not the racist white person who's
in the Ku Klux Klan that we have to
worry about it's the white liberal
Hillary Clinton supporter walking her
dog in Central Park
who would tell you right now she you
know she people like that oh I don't see
race races nobody feels me I see us all
the same I give to charities even the
most liberal well-intentioned white
person has a virus in his or her brain
that can be activated at an instant and
so what you're seeing now is a curtain
falling away you can't you can't have a
country this way this is the end of the
country
it is well what Van Jones is talking
about Cornel West is talking about what
Spike Lee in town lemon are talking
about it's the end of the country what
Charles was talking about in the New
York Times he has an article today again
using the riots and the looting as
self-justification
did they justify themselves he has a
piece Charles blow awful columnist he
says destructive power of despair the
protests are not necessarily about
Floyd's coming in particular but about
the savagery and carnage that his death
represents he says despair has an
incredible power to initiate destruction
it is exceedingly dangerous to assume
that oppression and pain can be
inflicted without consequence to believe
the victim will silently absorb the
injury and the wound will fade so now
he's just openly justifying looting and
rioting he says no the
compound particularly when there is no
effort to alter the system doing the
wounding no Avenue by which the
aggrieved can see justice the officer in
the George Floyd case is in jail right
now the people involved in the AH mode
are Barry case are in jail right now
that Central Park lady was fired from
her job what the hell are you talking
about he says this all breeds despair
simmering below the surface of building
up in need of release to be led out to
lash out to explode so now he's just
openly justifying riots as protests in
rioting have swept across the country in
the wake of the killing of George Floyd
by the police in Minneapolis it's
evident that America has failed to learn
that lesson yet again the protests are
not necessarily about Floyd's killing in
particular says Charles blow but about
the savagery and carnage that his death
represents the nearly unchecked ability
of the states to act with impunity in
the oppression of black bodies and the
taking the black life now from this
rhetoric you would think that literally
the 30 million black Americans are
living in everyday danger from the
police and that thousands of black
people are being mowed down by the
police indiscriminately every day in the
United States all of that is not true
and it has not been true for a very long
time the notion that every black person
in America is is under dire threat by
law enforcement is a lie it is a
statistical why it is not true and
people feel things that doesn't mean the
feelings are necessarily justified and
it certainly doesn't mean that the
feelings that lead to rioting and
looting are the same as the feelings
that lead to protesting so there's a
two-step that's being done here
one is that America that any instance of
brutalities and instance of racism and
there and it's that's it's actually a
three-step process one is any brutality
is racism two is any racism can be
attributed to the entire system and
three is if you attribute racism to the
entire system we cannot expect you to go
out and vote we can't expect you to
confine your activities to the legal
sooner or later it's gonna burst out
you're gonna start burning cop cars and
breaking into target
so Charles both says it's an anger over
feeling powerless stalked and hunted
degraded and dehumanized it's an anger
that the scenes keep repeating
themselves until one feels exhausted and
wrung out it's an anger over people
feeling over feeling that people in
power on every level are utterly
unresponsible to people's calls for
fundamental change and equal justice
under law and equal treatment by it what
is the call for change
don't just say institutional racism give
me a policy I can back I said you want
to talk about changing qualified
immunity for police officers we can have
a talk about that we have to change the
police union contract you know
public sector unions longer than any of
these liberals people on the right but
you want to talk about how America is
endemically racist and everybody has a
white virus in the brain like Van Jones
forget it there's no Republic to be had
there and you know it's you know what
else is not a solution what's not a
solution is the notion that every white
person is guilty for the sins of
America's past that's not a solution
either that's a recipe for destroying
the country so we saw this there's a
rally last night it was it was put out
I'm not sure exactly where this was them
but it was put out by a filmmaker and
photographer named Shaggy and it is a it
is a video of white Americans kneeling
down in front of black Americans
kneeling down in front of them and this
person's weeded a powerful show of unity
and support the white community Liat
kneeling down in front of the black
community to ask for forgiveness after
years of racism really is this Bull
Connor and George Wallace nailing down
or are these a bunch of people who are
not racist
kneeling in front of black people
because they're white I am not in favor
of anybody of any race kneeling down in
favor of anybody of any other race on
the basis of racial identity this isn't
America is built on the notion that
individuals are individuals the greatest
sins in America's history have come from
treating people as members of groups as
opposed to treating them as individuals
and yet what is being stumped for here
is the notion that America is indeed a
country in which groups vie for power
and that the only way that any sort of
change can be achieved is if one group
gives up power to another group as
opposed to equal justice under law
individuals treated with that justice
and D and fundamental human decency
being the basis of all of it now here's
the amazing thing here's the amazing
thing there's actual unity about the
things that I'm saying but it's being
obscured by politicians who are afraid
to say all of these things there's
unanimity about most of this and then
we'll get to the politicians hey the
truth is that that Floyds girlfriend for
example Floyd's girlfriend came out
yesterday and his family pleading for
peace asking for peace asking for the
rioting in the looting to stop meanwhile
Charles blow is excusing it even though
Don Lemon is excusing it even while
Lester Holt is conflating the the
violence and the protests Floyd's family
is saying please stop looting please
stop rioting this is not what George
Floyd was about please stop it
fight fire with fire you know everything
just burns and I I've seen it all day
today people hate their hating their
hating their hating their mad and he
would not want that you wouldn't he
wouldn't he will give grace he would I
stand on that that today he would still
give grace to those people
hey the and you see this from police
officers to her going out of their way
police officers in areas across the
country are going out of their way to
demonstrate no one you know you know
that hurt by police brutality you know
you know who gets hurt by police
brutality among various other targets
aside from people who are actually hurt
directly by police brutality the good
cops weren't lumped in with bad cops are
hurt by police brutality - I've talked
to enough cops across the country to
know I can't find a single cop will
defend anything that happened in that
video George Floyd really those police
officers and fire and ones in jail
Bellevue PD right over in Seattle sat
and talked with the protesters police
are what police want to work with
communities this is what they do every
single day to treat them all in lump
like the media is as just the the arms
keepers for a racist society is is
disgusting and unjustified here's a bail
of UPD over in over in Seattle talking
with protesters yesterday the officers
that were involved need to go to prison
for justice for George ploy and the
entire African American community we're
with you
yes we are with you we are not against
you I'm telling you the vast majority
law-enforcement and I could tell you
100% here in Bellevue when we saw it we
condemned the behavior we make sure that
that is never going to happen here we
embrace all of you god bless you how we
doing it let me tell you okay like
police and this was a bad way these were
the scenes that they were not showing on
the nationalist that's only on local
news right in in New Jersey police
started marching with the protesters
because guess who doesn't like police
brutality police officers who do the
right thing hey like this is where this
is where the hope of the country is hey
the hope of the country is in the
yes we are all a true decent but there's
a whole cast of people out there who
want to portray America is divided
between the indecent and the decent and
the indecent are nearly everybody in
America and the decent are the victims
of that in just unjust terrible America
this is over in New Jersey the police
marching with the protesters right there
is an officer in Fargo North Dakota
holding a sign with the protesters over
in Santa Cruz
the police were taking a knee now listen
I don't like he taking a knee routine
because again I have objected to his
Kaepernick I object to it when it's
these protesters I objected on it's cops
they taking a knee suggest that all of
America is indicated in this situation I
do not think that is true and I think
that if you took a poll of Americans
99.999% of them want this officer in
prison including 99.999% of cops by the
way people in the black community are
not in favor of the rioting in the
looting only people in the media who
gets to sit in their cushy mansions are
in favor of the rioting and the looting
most members of the black community are
not in favor of this rioting and looting
the Atlanta mayor right who's black said
yesterday to the rioters go home you're
not doing any good for the country not
doing any good for any cause here you're
not doing any good for anything this
city that has had a legacy of black
mayors and black police chiefs and
people who care about this city where
more than 50% of the business owners and
metro Atlanta are minority business
owners if you care about this city then
go home and pray that somebody like
Reverend Beasley will come and talk to
you and give you some instructions on
what a protest should look like and how
you affects your weight change in
America good for her that's Keisha Lance
bottoms the Atlanta mayor the same Paul
mayor who also is black he said people
who burn businesses are not driven by
love of community right this is it these
are local leaders who understand that
this is not this is not the right thing
to do now we're gonna contrast some of
this leadership with the leadership that
you seen from white mayors of major
cities like Los Angeles in New York
which is absolutely cowardly into cell
animus here's the st. Paul mayor saying
people who burn businesses aren't driven
by love of community or by any cause
they're doing this because they're bad
people
what we know is there's some people in
our
unity there's some people in our streets
who are driven there by a passion for
our community by a love for our
community and by a deep desire to never
see the painful loss of life like the
killing like the video of the killing of
George Floyd that we all saw this week
and then there's folks in our streets
who are there to burn down our
black-owned barber shops to burn down
our family-owned businesses our
immigrant owned restaurants and it is
very clear to me that those people are
not driven by a love for our community
and there's no way you can argue that
those actions are designed to produce a
better future for our community quite
the opposite this is exactly right why
we're Democrats these meddling virtually
all this is happening in Democrat run
major cities virtually all of it is
happening in Democratic major cities and
if you're a decent mayor you understand
that law-abiding citizens in your city
black white green brown Democrat
Republican need to be protected from
people who are committing acts of
violence and you are doing no favors to
anybody by allowing this to go on but
that's not what you have seen from
Democratic politicians who are so
interested in the intersectional game to
be made by basically cowing to all of
this but they're not willing to say
anything remotely true it's pretty
amazing Joe Biden took 48 hours 48 hours
to condemn the violence he put out he
put out a statement early on Sunday
morning very very carefully worded
statement saying these last few days
have laid bare that we are a nation
furious at injustice every person of
conscience can understand the rawness of
the trauma people of color experience in
this country from the daily indignities
to the extreme violence like the
horrific killing of George Floyd now
once again this is underscoring the sort
of CNN Charles blow dynamic America's a
deeply racist evil country ok and at the
same time we all condemn it so like
which is it our Americans angry at
racism or our Americans complicit and
racism Joe Biden can't make up his mind
he said protesting such brutality is
right and necessary it's an utterly
American response burning down
communities and needless destruction is
not violence that in dangerous lives is
not violence that guts and shutters
businesses that serve the community is
not the act of protesting should never
be allowed to overshadow the reason we
protest it should not drive people away
from the Just Cause that protest is
meant to advance okay and then he just
goes on in this painting it's come 48
hours to do that 48 hours to give that
sort of mild condemnation and then you
by the way this is this you want you
want a benefit Trump this will benefit
from pretty strongly campaign staffers
for Biden we're donating to a group and
Minnesota bailing out people who are
violating the law Andrew Bates a Biden
campaign spokesperson told the News
Service that Biden opposes the
institution of cash bail is a modern-day
debtors prison they're bailing out all
of these people who had committed crimes
this is like this is this is what you're
seeing from Democratic politicians
you're seeing it from from some
Democratic administrators in various
cities the Raleigh North Carolina police
department head said we're not even
defend property we're just gonna allow
people to go and burn the property this
is very reminiscent of the riots in
Baltimore back in 2014 when the mayor
said that they were going to give the
protesters and rioters and looters space
to burn
okay so meanwhile Bill DeBlasio the
mayor of New York again he doesn't have
the balls to say what the mayor of
Atlanta or the mayor of st. Paul said so
instead he says I'm the problem Bill
DeBlasio is the problem I acknowledge my
white privilige okay as opposed to this
is a major American city and we will not
allow long lawlessness to prevail and we
are working hard every day to stop
police brutality and make sure that the
law is enforced instead we get bill de
blasio saying I am white privilege and I
understand my own privilege how is this
helpful in any way the answer is it's
not it's just part of the program to do
legitimize the country as a whole we
can't go on like this and I'm talking to
everyone but I'm particularly talking to
white New Yorkers to say we can't go on
like this the entire nation watches
George Floyd killed in broad daylight by
someone who's supposed to protect us
with no concern at all his killer seemed
to have no emotion about the fact that
he was killing a black man as if there
was no value in that man and
unfortunately that's what the history of
this country has taught to many people
okay why are white in your question why
should white New Yorkers have to learn
that lesson or white New Yorkers going
out and killing black people on the
streets did I missed that part bill de
blasio or are you just a terrible person
also if you're gonna talk about the case
you might as well you know stick to the
evidence of the case it is a case of
police brutality there has yet to be
brought any evidence that this was an
element of racism you could try to
embrace ISM maybe it was racism we don't
know yet but the idea that the history
of America is white
not caring about black people and
therefore George Floyd is dead
he said he by the way that if George
Floyd were white he'd be alive today I
have no idea where he is coming up with
that evidence really he like a shred of
evidence there would be a nice thing but
Bill de Blasio's a garbage mayor he
should resign he's horrible at his job
speaking of garbage mayor's my Mayor
Eric Garcetti he tweeted out over the
weekend that he wasn't gonna call for
the National Guard because that would
just be escalating things and then of
course he immediately came out and
called for the National Guard cuz it
turns out he's not in control of his own
City because he was too busy cowering
before protesters and then really
cowering before rioters and looters
I spoke with the governor earlier today
this is not a city this is not 1992
we're not going to evoke what happened
then and call in the National Guard but
that's also on all of us let's just all
deescalate we've trained police officers
to learn more and more about
de-escalation and we still have more to
do but all of us as human beings can
deescalate you can escalate without a
weapon you can provoke without a baton
so let us all deescalate and no I do not
anticipate in any way needing to call in
a National Guard we got this Los Angeles
let's show our better angels yeah and
then five hours later who's calling in
the National Guard he literally said
like hours later the California National
Guard is being deployed to Los Angeles
overnight to support our local response
to maintain peace and safety on the
streets of our city yeah it turns out
that that basically that basically
preparing to take it from riders and
looters and begging them to show the
better angels of their nature is not a
particularly productive move it's just
it's amazing it's amazing amazing stuff
our politicians are so cowardly
and speaking of cowardly our
corporations are similarly cowardly so
corporations have been putting out
statements to try and demonstrate that
they are on board with the social
justice arguments that America is deeply
racist and terrible the idea being of
course that if they virtues signal that
America is deeply racist and terrible
then maybe they'll be left alone that's
the way this works in corporate America
too often these days is that it's not
enough to simply like I don't know why
you need to hear from corporate leaders
about the killing of George Floyd I
wasn't aware that corporate leaders were
making police policy like if if you want
to on your individual capacity that's
fine but seriously I don't really care
about target's policy on
on anything target is a store where I
buy things when did it become the idea
that put that that target is supposed to
issue a corporate statement on every
element of politics wait it they're
allowed to I'm just pointing out the
fact that it is a very odd thing that so
many members of these of these various
institutions now feel the need to virtue
signal so that they will whatnot be
targeted not be boycotted and that
that's the idea here
so you had for example peloton put out a
letter suggesting that that they are
standing with black lives matter the
whitest company on earth standing with
with black lives matter and they talked
about donating five hundred thousand
dollars to the n-double-a-cp Legal
Defense and Educational Fund so
basically don't yell at us where a
corporation don't break our windows over
this thing now what does peloton have to
do with any of this the answer is
nothing did Pella like did was George
Floyd killed with a peloton he was not
they peloton have anything to do with
this the answer is no if the CEO wants
to March
you should go March if the individuals
want to go March they should go March
but the fact that every corporation now
feels the need to write emails to the
entire public at large signaling their
politics on questions as to whether
America is endemically racist like it's
just it's in a minute like that the
pressure tactics that are being brought
to bear on corporations and the
willingness of corporations to go along
with it it's pretty incredible it's
pretty incredible meanwhile President
Trump is involved here but he's only
involved apparently likes you're kind of
tangentially the President of the United
States does not seem to be supremely
involved in all this politicians wanna
blame him for all of this obviously is
that this is what you've seen from
politicians so so the the Attorney
General pointed out that there were some
and he feel like tactics here that an
Tifa is involved here media immediately
came out to defendant even pretend the
Nancy fees not a group that exists here
is the Department of Justice had
explaining that we are seeing some
organized terror like activities here in
many places it appears the violence is
planned organized and driven by an
arctic and left extremist groups far
left extremist groups using an Tifa like
Dick's many of whom travel from outside
the state to promote the violence okay
meanwhile the president was tweeting out
about all of this and you just basically
been on Twitter he have a speech on
Saturday in which he said he stands
against violence and mayhem but mostly
he's been on Twitter so he tweeted out
there was a little bit of a speech
talking about violence and ma'am every
citizen in every community has the right
to be safe in their workplace safe in
their homes and safe in our city streets
this is the sacred right of all
Americans that I am totally determined
to defend and will defend my
administration will always stand against
violence mayhem and disorder okay no
that's good yeah and like that he he
should be saying and he should be
assuring Americans that they're not
gonna be confined to their homes for the
foreseeable future because of ridiculous
and cowardly local leadership but
president from has basically mostly been
on Twitter fulminating about antiva and
I'm sorry Twitter is not a substitute
for being president so President Trump
tweeted out something along the lines of
he wants to he said the United States of
America will be designating an Tifa as a
terrorist organization people cheer okay
affectionately under American law you
can't do that there there are terror
laws they generally apply to foreign
based terror organizations because you
run into serious problems of prosecuting
people on First Amendment basis for a
quote-unquote domestic terrorism other
than laws that re exists like attempt to
do damage attempted to harm across state
lines he's been tweeting out things like
law and order in all capital letters
he's been he's been tweeting out about
how crossing state lines to incite
violence is a federal crime liberal
governors and mayor's must get much
tougher on federal government or the
federal government will step in and do
what has to be done that includes using
the unlimited power of our military and
many arrests thank you
like all of this is is like I don't have
a problem of anything Trump is tweeting
I'm just wondering like he's the
president it would be good for him to to
do something about this like what actual
activity is happening to get tough
Democrat mayors and governors these
people are anarchists calling our
National Guard now the world is watching
me laughing at you and sleepy Joe is
this what America wants no like okay
again he's right but this is ineffective
this is ineffective now what's hilarious
about this is that the ineffective
response from Trump which has been
mainly just tweeting stuff is blamed by
the media for all of this so it's always
Trump's fault America's fault its
Trump's fault it's never the fault of
rioters and looters who want to steal
the TV it's never the fault of people
just wanna burn stuff down it's not an
cephas fault
in fact joy read on MSNBC was out
full-on defending an Tifa over the
weekend she tweeted out what's weird is
that if you spelled out with the acronym
for this loose movement called an tyfa
stands for and rewrite from suite
accordingly it would read the United
States of America will be designating
anti-fascists as a terrorist
organization okay if you're stupid
enough that you believe antifa is
anti-fascist in actual practice as
opposed to just name it's because you
are a complete moor and your drop down
your head as a baby that's like
believing that the Democratic People's
Republic of North Korea is an actual
Democratic People's Republic just
because you call yourself anti-fascist
doesn't mean that you are not a fascist
and Tifa shuts down free speech they
beat people for wearing the wrong hat
they attempt to shut down I mean I've
been when I spoke in Berkeley they
showed up and they attempted to shut
down speech like this is what an t4 does
and Tifa is garbage and the fact that
members of the media are willing to
defend them it just demonstrates where
the media is sympathies lie one MSNBC
contributor said we are now on the verge
of Trump designating his enemies enemies
of the state he's gonna he's gonna crack
down he's gonna violate their rights
like right now I saw it last night
that the World War Two memorial the week
after Memorial Day was defaced by Ann
Tifa I mean with the actual anarchist
symbols and everything and and yet we
have MSNBC contributor suggesting the
problem here is that Trump is being mean
to an Tifa so loosely based and so
diverse in their beliefs from global
Anarchy to simple a simple anti Trump to
supporting black lives matter that you
cannot isolate a single body of
political or ideology ideological
beliefs here so I am concerned that if
we're not careful this is one small step
away from the President of the United
States designating his political
opponents as enemies of the state as
terrorists oh yes I'm sure that's what's
happening here is that he's just going
to lock up everyone he disagrees with as
opposed to you know the people who are
actually beating heads in
and breaking into target and and and and
burning police stations meanwhile Nancy
Pelosi sees of course blaming Trump what
what I love is that it's Trump so
Trump's responsible for the rioting in
the looting he's Fanning the flames but
if you claim that America is a deeply
racist place in which one group of
Americans namely white Americans have
been systemically oppressing black
Americans at the same level for 400
years that Americans were like from 1619
to now have basically acted the same way
toward black Americans that police
officers across the nation are randomly
executing black men for no reason at all
that's not Fanning the flames but if
Trump says Antipa that's Fanning the
flames or if Trump wheat something dumb
that's what's really Fanning the flames
here it's not the it's not the
generations long indoctrination and the
idea that America is gravely evil that
America's Constitution is rooted in
racism and slavery and evil that
America's Declaration of Independence is
a lie it's not that stuff that's Fanning
the flames so it's really Fanning the
flames that Trump is president which is
weird because I remember race riots in
the United States in 2014 when Donald
Trump was not president here is Nancy
Pelosi President of the United States
should be danger to the office that he
serves it should be a unifying force in
our country we have seen that with
Democratic and Republican presidents all
along they have seen their
responsibility to be the President of
the United States to unify our country
and not to fuel the flame okay same
Nancy Pelosi said that the case in
Minnesota was the case of an execution
was an actual execution it wasn't a case
of manslaughter it wasn't a case of
assault it was a case of an execution
same Nancy Pelosi but but Trump is
Fanning the flames and then the DC Mayor
came and said Trump is harkening back to
segregation why because he tweeted when
people are trying to break into the
White House that we have vicious dogs in
here as though as though Trump is
actually like looking up the language of
Bull Connor it's like I'm gonna reach
the vicious dogs against black Americans
how about guys if you if you climb that
fence we got some stuff in here is the
White House bad idea like do you really
think here's the thing that from do you
think that Trump is a master of subtlety
and making historical references is that
really what you think this is so stupid
on every level it's stupid it's not
Fanning the flames for CNN to be out
there basically suggesting that rioting
and looting are natural outgrowth of the
evils of American racism but it is
Fanning the flames for president Trump
them
there are dogs at the white house he
play a helpful role still or is it too
late well I think that the president has
a responsibility to help calm the nation
and he can start by not sending divisive
tweets that are meant to hearken to the
segregationist past of our country and
he can start by doing that
right now yes I'm sure it was a
reference to segregation when he talked
about dogs meanwhile the same media are
also trying to blame President Trump for
the four kovat right they're blaming him
for Kovan but if you mention that by the
way you guys all stop talking about Kobe
the minute that the protesters agree
with your generalized perception that
America is evil then you're bad so Susan
Hennessy who's a reporter she tweeted
out I can't believe the President Trump
is gonna blame this for an uptick in
COBIT well if there's enough to kinko
but it seems like maybe tens of
thousands of people gathering and
shouting input in in close quarters with
one another without wearing masks that
might be a problem Susan Hennessy is the
brookings senior fellow in CNN national
security and legal analyst she tweeted
out as coronavirus numbers climbed from
here I think it is a safe assumption
that Trump will now attempt to blame
these protests for the spread rather
than his own inadequate and incompetent
response I mean if there is a spread
from the protests it seems like that
might be a good thing to point out then
maybe the protec like amazing how cove
819 was only ended as soon as the media
found a shinier object as soon as the
media found a shiny object namely we
like these protests cuz they say
america's bad then I guess Kovan 19 is
not a worry anymore and if you point out
that Kobe 19 is still a worry gathering
in major numbers and screaming at the
top of your lungs with your spittle
flying everywhere which is what happens
when you scream whether you're singing
in the church or screaming at a protest
then you're very very very bad then
you're very terrible our media just and
our politicians this class you know and
then they say let us protect you why
would anybody why would anybody need to
protect themselves in the United States
of America yeah you've been doing a
bang-up job really really well done
alrighty well we'll be back here a
little bit later today with a lot of
additional content this stuff is
unfolding in real time stay safe out
there and demand more of your
politicians and your government demand
more of your politicians in government
and demand more of people who suggest
that America is endemic
evil decent people agree on all of these
things and if you suggest that other
people don't agree with you because you
don't like the color of their skin and
that is likely because you are the
indecent person in this particular
situation we've acted a little bit later
today on two additional hours of
contents I'll be on all-access live
tonight or we'll see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel I
douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the ben
shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2025 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]